*Générique avec musique entraînante*
*Musique d'information*
http://bonjour bienvenue dans fast flood le journaux des réseaux social
Au sommaire de cette édition une nouvelle tendance
Qui émerge sur AssBook
Et l'invité du jour un véritable mystère des internets
Mais on commence comme chaque semaine avec le truite de la semaine
qui est signé Rodrigue Perez qui nous dit :
Si mon sexe était un barre de métro, je ne banderai pas tous les jours
Au vu de certaines manucures on le comprends
Passons tout de suite à notre premier sujet concernant Ass Book
Et pour nous en parler et bien c'est Gilles Manouche
qui est avec nous. Alors Gilles qu'est ce que vous faites ?
Bonjour ! Et bien tout le monde connait le babysitting
Ou bien aujourd'hui le dogsitting
Quand vous partez en vacances, il y a quelqu'un dont on doit s'occuper aussi
Et auquel on ne pense pas souvent
Qui est-ce ?
Et oui c'est AssBook !
Ma société s'occupe de votre AssBook
quand vous n'êtes pas là
On s'engage à déconnecter, reconnecter votre compte
au moins 3 fois par jour
pour décourager les voleurs de compte justement
Incroyable ! Ça c'est vraiment malin
Alors comment s'appelle votre service ?
C'est l'alliance de AssBook et du babysitting !
Pouf !
Le AssSitting !
*Rire étouffé*
Le AssSitting ?
Mais que-ce c'est justement s'asseoir sur le visage de votre...... ?
Oui bon *rire géné*
Effectivement au moment ou on a trouvé le nom
On s'est dit à c'est bien à tout ça puis après y a un ami qui nous l'a dit
Mais bon le problème c'est qu'on avait déjà acheté l .com
On avait déjà sortie "ANIPI"
Alors on s'est dit qu'on allait surement en parler
*Murmure de plus en plus loin*
*Bruit de porte qui claque*
Société ! Je ne parle pas du fromage
#Blagues Mais si certains vont un faire un de fromage
Au tous cas, moi je n'ai pas de trou
*Respiration aspiré*
Société ! Un véritable mystère des internets
Ils fleurissent un peu partout sur les réseaux social
Mais on ne connait pas leur origine
se sont les OSEF
Après une enquête altente,
notre équipe a réussi à trouver l'auteur
de ces fameux OSEF
Il est là pour nous en parler ! C'est Nicolas Futre !
Alors Nicolas, pour que les téléspectateurs comprennent bien
de quoi il s'agit. On va essayer de rappeler
comment vous créer ces fameux OSEF
Vous allez d'abord sur internet regarder
une vidéo ou un article
Vous créez un compte
vous vous y connectez
pour laisser finalement le message "On S'En Fout"
qui en langage internet s'écrit "OSEF"
C'est bien ça ?
OSEF !
OSEF Staline ! (jeu de mot Joseph Staline)
Très bien !
OSEF  Staline !
Voilà merci  Nicolas !
C'est la fin de ce fast flood, le journaux de réseaux social
OSEF phine BAKER (jeu de mot Joséphine BAKER)
N'oubliez surtout pas de follow de ff
OSEF des Asgardiens
FFassFlood
*Bruit génant*
OSEF l'ami de ratons laveurs
Des
Ma famille
*Musique énergique*